y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia de kobe 19 a continuación les
presento algunos de los temas que vamos
a tener hoy en el programa
varios temas destacados esta semana en
eeuu hablaremos por ejemplo de los
despidos masivos en el sector de la
salud a raíz de la obligatoriedad de
estar vacunado para poder continuar con
sus labores un pedido que hizo el
presidente joe biden también a propósito
del presidente de bailén recibió su
tercera dosis o dosis de refuerzo
también daremos un vistazo a las cifras
en eeuu el número de casos y fallecidos
y también cómo está el avance de la
vacunación también en su reporte semanal
la organización mundial de la salud lado
ms indicó que hay un destacado descenso
en el número de casos positivos de kobe
19 y una de las regiones donde más han
bajado los números es en américa lo
mismo sucede con la cifra de fallecidos
han disminuido con respecto a la semana
pasada excepto en áfrica y en europa aún
así las cifras son alentadoras aunque
todo puede cambiar con la llegada del
invierno boreal en norteamérica y en
europa y en nuestra habitual consulta
con el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
tenemos una agenda con muchos puntos
para conversar conversaremos por ejemplo
una posible nueva combinación de vacunas
también hablaremos de una serie de
medicamentos en píldora elaborado por
diferentes farmacéuticas como merck y
pfizer que sirve para combatir el kobe
19 al parecer tiene un alto porcentaje
para evitar la muerte de los pacientes
que ya están contagiados con el
coronavirus
pues vamos a comenzar el programa y lo
hacemos con números globales con datos
alentadores el número de casos de
muertes y contagios de kobe 19 continúa
en descenso a lo largo de esta semana
así lo indicó el informe semanal de la
organización mundial de la salud lado ms
veamos entonces los detalles de este
reporte esta semana fueron
contabilizados 10% menos casos de
contagio a nivel global para un total de
3.3 millones de casos en todo el planeta
también fueron reportados el 15 por
ciento menos fallecidos esta semana
fueron contabilizados 55 mil fallecidos
que igual sigue siendo una cifra alta
pero bueno con respecto a la cifra de la
semana pasada es un poco menor en europa
y en áfrica la cifra no ha mejorado y se
mantienen similares a los de la semana
pasada
las regiones con las mayores descensos
de casos y fallecidos son el medio
oriente pacífico occidental y nuestro
continente américa
sigamos hablando de las cifras
hablaremos entonces del avance que ha
tenido la pandemia para esta semana en
el continente americano vamos a ver la
actualización del número de casos y de
fallecidos en algunos países vamos a
comenzar en el extremo norte en canadá
allí terminan la semana con más de 1.6
millones de casos confirmados y más de
27 mil 900 personas ya han fallecido por
el cob el 19 en mexico la cifra ya
supera los 3.6 millones de casos
confirmados
277.500 personas un poco más de estas
cifras ya han fallecido hasta el momento
vámonos para américa del sur ecuador ha
ya superó las 500 9000 personas con
casos positivos las víctimas se cuentan
ya por encima de los 32 mil 700 más al
sur en chile hay más de 1.6 millones de
casos confirmados los fallecidos superan
37 mil 400 y bolivia esta semana superó
los 500 mil casos allí los fallecidos
también superan los 18 mil 700
vamos entonces a eeuu en donde hubo
varios temas varios anuncios importantes
a lo largo de esta semana el tema de la
obligatoriedad de la vacuna está
generando divisiones en la sociedad
estadounidense mientras que avanza la
inoculación de la tercera dosis también
en un sector de la sociedad vamos
entonces a la ciudad de nueva york allí
se encuentra mamen sala para darnos más
detalles hola am avn gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa y
comenzamos hablando primero del
presidente yo va a ir en que recibió la
tercera dosis de su vacuna
si el presidente estadounidense joe
biden ha recibido esta semana la tercera
dosis de la vacuna de facer justo seis
meses después de haber recibido la
segunda dosis y por qué lo hace pues
porque está dentro de ese reducido grupo
de población en los que se ha aprobado
una tercera dosis de refuerzo estos son
las personas mayores de 65 años
recordemos que yo vaivén tiene 78 las
personas con enfermedades como diabetes
o la obesidad o aquellos trabajadores
que son más susceptibles que están más
cerca de poder contagiarse como son por
ejemplo los profesores y los sanitarios
el presidente yo wyden quería que toda
la población a elegibles recibiera esa
tercera dosis de refuerzo para luchar de
manera más fuerte contra la variante
delta que se extiende rápido y es mucho
más contagiosa pero las autoridades
sanitarias no lo han aprobado más que en
este reducido grupo de la población de
momento solamente se aprueba esta
tercera dosis en la vacuna de facer no
se ha hecho aún en la de moderna que es
por ejemplo la que se administró la
vicepresidenta kamala harris o en la de
johnson and johnson hay que decir
también que la organización mundial de
la salud está en contra de esta tercera
dosis porque dice que hay muchos países
subdesarrollados que ni siquiera tienen
vacunas para toda la población y que
antes habría que terminar de vacunar a
toda la población posible el presidente
joe biden se defiende de estas críticas
asegurando que eeuu ha sido uno de los
países que más vacunas ha donado a estos
países ante el tercer mundo estos países
subdesarrollados sin ir más lejos en el
2022 donará 1100 millones de vacunas bam
en hay una controversia en eeuu o por
los despidos masivos de personas que
trabajan en el sector salud que no han
querido vacunarse el gobierno federal
les ha exigido que tienen que estar
completamente vacunados para poder
seguir ejerciendo su labor qué es lo que
sucede allí
y acabar con la pandemia pasa por
conseguir la inmunización de un más de
un 70% de la población y eso implica
vacunar a toda la gente que sea posible
por eso en algunos estados hemos
empezado a ver esta semana ya despidos
de personal sanitario que se niega a
vacunarse por ejemplo en carolina del
norte hay 180 trabajadores sanitarios
despedidos y se ha suspendido a 375 más
por negarse a ponerse la vacuna en texas
ha ocurrido algo parecido son ya 150
empleados a los que se ha despedido
dicen que no quieren ponerse la vacuna
porque no todas están aceptadas
totalmente algunas solamente para uso de
emergencia y además dicen que es ilegal
que les obliguen al no curarse una
vacuna aquí en el estado de nueva york
hemos de decir que la mayoría de los
sanitarios han aceptado vacunarse al
menos un 90% de los trabajadores entre
los hospitales tienen ya al menos una
dosis de la vacuna apuesta de esos 11
hospitales que hay aquí por ejemplo en
la ciudad de nueva york pero todavía
quedan cerca de 5 mil trabajadores que
se niegan a hacerlo y esta misma semana
podrían sus puestos de trabajo lo que
está haciendo la ciudad y el estado de
nueva york para contrarrestar esa falta
de trabajadores que puede haber a raíz
de despedir porque son lleguen a
vacunarse es llamar a aquellas personas
a aquellos doctores aquellos
trabajadores sanitarios que sean
jubilados ya para que en caso de que sea
necesario puedan venir a ayudar a los
hospitales en caso de que vuelva a ver
otro repunte o sea necesaria su ayuda en
estos hospitales
seguiremos oyendo de estos despidos a lo
largo de las próximas semanas sin duda
alguna mamen pasemos ahora a las cifras
cómo avanza la vacunación cómo avanzan
los contagios los fallecidos allí en
eeuu
si por un lado tenemos los datos en la
población más infantil que
desgraciadamente están aumentando los
contagios sobre todo teniendo en cuenta
que acaban de regresar a las aulas pero
lo que se refiere a los adultos hemos de
decir que los datos son cada vez más
alentadores en las próximas cuatro
semanas descenderá el número de
fallecidos por kobe 19 y también
tendremos la tercera semana consecutiva
con menos hospitalizaciones desde hace
bastantes meses estos son los
pronósticos que han hecho de manera
conjunta los centros para el control y
prevención de enfermedades del país
ahora mismo en eeuu hay una media de
2.000 fallecidos diarios por kobe y 19 y
cerca de 114 mil personas se continúan
infectando cada día unos datos que cada
vez van a mejor pero como veis todavía
son importantes y hay que hacerle frente
sobre todo ahora lo que pregunta lo que
preocupa también a las autoridades
sanitarias es que se acercan las
celebraciones de halloween y las
celebraciones del día de acción de
gracias que como sabéis aquí muchas
familias se reúnen para celebrar este
día y eso preocupa los espero que se
pueda convertir en eventos propagadores
del virus porque no debemos olvidar que
en este país todavía quedan 70 millones
de adultos elegibles para recibir esa
vacuna que no han querido vacunarse esto
es todavía un 20 por ciento de la
población y se sigue apostando a cecilia
apoyando y se sigue trabajando para
convencer a la población de que se
vacune y poder llegar a esa inmunidad
del grupo que es lo más importante para
poder vencer a la pandemia amén muchas
gracias por este completo reporte desde
la ciudad de nueva york que vale la pena
destacar también mamen que el estado de
california se ha convertido en el primer
estado de eeuu en exigir la vacuna
contra el kobe 19 para los estudiantes
de 12 años en adelante veamos ahora
entonces cómo está avanzando la
vacunación en nuestro continente en
américa para el cierre de esta semana
les vamos a presentar el porcentaje de
las personas que hayan recibido el
esquema completo de la vacunación vamos
a comenzar entonces con las cifras de
mexico en donde la vacunación completa
de alcanza el 34 punto 99 por ciento de
la población mexicana en república
dominicana alcanza ya el 40 otro punto
71% de la población con esquema completo
en colombia la cifra esta semana repunta
hasta el 32 puntos 79 por ciento en
bolivia alcanzaron para el cierre de
esta semana al 27 punto 54 por ciento de
los habitantes y vamos a finalizar con
brasil en donde la cifra ya alcanzó el
42 punto 46 por ciento de los ciudadanos
con el esquema completo de la vacunación
vemos ahora un vistazo a la actualidad
en colombia allí para conocer más
detalles vamos entonces a la redacción
de france 24 en bogotá allí se encuentra
mi compañero santiago ariztía santiago
como siempre un gusto tenerte en el
programa muchas gracias por acompañarnos
hoy y las autoridades colombianas
indicaron que el primero de octubre
sería la fecha para la inoculación de la
tercera dosis pero ha habido
incumplimientos en las entregas de los
lotes de las vacunas por parte de la
farmacéutica moderna que dicen las
autoridades
santiago según indicó el director del
departamento administrativo de la
presidencia de colombia hablamos de
víctor monjos colombia recibió 1.4
millones de dosis procedentes de eeuu
pese a que estamos hablando de una cifra
bastante generosa y que va a ayudar al
plan de vacunación colombia recibió sólo
2 millones de dosis de la vacuna de la
farmacéutica moderna de las 4 millones
que estaban pactadas para este mes junio
se especificó que estas dosis recibidas
eran destinadas para la aplicación de
segundas dosis de la población
habilitada en lo que es el plan nacional
de vacunación de colombia y para la
próxima semana se esperan más de 5
millones de dosis de biológicos de las
farmacéuticas como astrazéneca fisheries
johnson and johnson
santiago ya lo decía yo en la
presentación que el primero de octubre
fue la fecha elegida por el gobierno
colombiano para empezar a inocular la
tercera dosis o dosis de refuerzo que
información adicional hay al respecto
sobre cómo va a ser el plan para esta
tercera dosis
claro efectivamente de santiago este
primero de octubre fue la fecha que
eligieron las autoridades para comenzar
con el plan de vacunación de la dosis de
refuerzo o tercera dosis que será
específicamente recordemos para la
población mayor de 70 años para esta
etapa del plan de inoculación las
vacunas disponibles son las
desarrolladas por sinovac astrazéneca
por facer y también modernas las
autoridades especificaron que las
personas que reciban como tercera dosis
biológicos de facer o de modernas que
son de arn mensajero pueden llegar a
tener una sintomatología mayor a la que
sintieron con la dosis de sinovac o de
astrazéneca y no hay ningún tipo de
peligro si hay combinación de biológicos
la tercera dosis santiago estará también
disponible para los colombianos que se
vacunaron en el exterior
santiago gracias por esta actualización
de la situación en colombia como siempre
un gusto que nos acompañe en el programa
santiago aristidas desde la redacción de
france 24 ahora demos un vistazo una
mirada a las cifras globales en paraguay
vamos a profundizar en unos minutos con
nuestro corresponsal en asunción pero
antes veamos como cierran la semana allí
en este y suramericano con más de
459.000 casos más de 16.000 personas han
fallecido en paraguay por el cob y 19 el
25.85 por ciento de la población ya
tiene el esquema completo de vacunación
en este país el 92 punto 86% de los
casos son de la variante delta de la
variante gamma solamente el 4.76 por
ciento de los casos y el 2.38 por ciento
de los casos está repartido en otras
variantes
esas son las cifras pero veamos entonces
qué es lo que está pasando allí en
paraguay vamos a ver en detalle con
nuestro corresponsal en la ciudad de
asunción fernando box ya nos va a dar
más información fernando como siempre un
gusto saludarlo y hablemos de las cifras
ya comenzábamos a dar algunas pero
actualizamos con lo que ha dicho el
gobierno en cifras generales en todo
paraguay
paraguay sigue reduciendo sus muertes y
contagios diarios por ccoo y 19 desde
hace 2 meses que las estadísticas
muestran un descenso continuo de casos y
hoy en día los hospitales ya estan
descongestionados de pacientes un
ejemplo de este drástico descenso es que
a mediados de años paraguay era uno de
los países con mayor tasa de mortalidad
por el coronavirus en todo el mundo hace
unos días luego de un año y medio del
gobierno volvió a informar sobre cero
muertes diarias por coronavirus esto fue
festejado por muchos como una clara
señal de que es posible superar este año
la pandemia la llegada de la variante
delta el país no significó todavía un
retroceso en ese sentido sin embargo las
autoridades sanitarias paraguayas
observan con preocupación lo que ocurrió
en brasil donde si se detectó un aumento
de contagios de la variante de delta
esto preocupa debido a que
históricamente la situación sanitaria
brasileña termina repercutiendo en la
paraguaya como dicen muchos
epidemiólogos locales cuando brasil se
resfría paraguay estornudo bueno la
emergencia se mantiene pero es bueno ver
que en paraguay las cifras se han
comenzado a bajar y a pesar de este
panorama que es alentador el gobierno
sigue manteniendo restricciones que
restricciones se mantienen allí cuales
han sido levantadas cómo está la
situación alguien paraguay
las restricciones que apuntan a frenar
el contagio de la enfermedad fueron
disminuyendo en los últimos meses y
actualmente están permitidas las clases
presenciales en todos los niveles de
escolaridad así como actividades
grupales de índole deportiva o cultural
bajo ciertos parámetros no obstante el
gobierno mantiene por decreto ciertas
exigencias como el uso obligatorio de
mascarillas la prohibición de
aglomerarse en discotecas y otros
eventos y la imposibilidad de circular
en cualquier calle del país entre las 2
y las 5 de la madrugada la segunda
semana de octubre el gobierno realizará
un nuevo balance para determinar si
paraguay ya puede acoplarse a la lista
de países que dejaron de exigir el uso
obligatorio de tapabocas al aire libre
si los índices epidemiológicos siguen a
la baja el poder ejecutivo ya anunció
que va a flexibilizar aún más las
medidas sanitarias para volver a cierto
tipo de normalidad en todo el país
fernando paraguay fue uno de los últimos
países en américa la tienen comenzar el
plan de vacunación como está avanzando o
se ha logrado poner un poco más al día
con respecto a otros países vecinos como
están
un poco menos del 40% de la población
total de 7.300.000 habitantes de
paraguay recibió al menos una dosis de
la vacuna contra el coronavirus aquellos
que tienen su esquema completo de
vacunación representan sólo el 25% el
ministerio de salud tiene este objetivo
para antes de terminar el año vacunar a
un millón cien mil personas mayores de
18 años que todavía no recibieron
ninguna dosis la escasez de vacunas
sigue siendo un problema para el
gobierno de mario habló esta semana nada
más el ministro de salud julio gorda
hizo un nuevo reclamo ante el consejo
permanente de la oea por un acceso más
oportuno justo y equitativo a las
vacunas este reclamo fue constante por
parte del gobierno para guayas el
mecanismo kóvacs por el incumplimiento
del calendario de entrega de las dosis
compradas por el gobierno paraguayo en
ese sentido la mayor crítica hacia el
presidente mario abdo benítez durante la
pandemia sigue siendo la incapacidad de
adquirir a tiempo y forma las vacunas
contra el coronavirus la mayoría de las
más de 5.500.000 dosis que llegaron
hasta ahora paraguay fueron producto de
donaciones de gobiernos extranjeros
fernando gracias por este reporte desde
la ciudad de asunción fernando boxea
nuestro corresponsal allí en paraguay
vamos ahora con la consulta con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez infectólogo
y asesor científico de france24 doctor
pérez bienvenido como siempre un gusto
saludarlo abrimos nuestra agenda muchos
temas para la noche de hoy a propósito
de que colombia comenzó a poner la
tercera dosis como lo estábamos
anunciando hace unos minutos vuelve
también a surgir el tema de la polémica
al debate en torno a la combinación de
las vacunas en este caso de la vacuna de
astrazéneca y la sputnik light
si hay que tener en cuenta que esta
pauta que se llama pauta pero logan es
usar todos mecanismos diferentes de
vacunas están asociadas y donde más
estudios hay es en la vacuna astrazéneca
con países o los estudios que se han
hecho entre faster y modernas que son me
han mostrado su seguridad por otro lado
esta vacuna es por mí pues se ponen está
en algunos países de américa latina no
en todos y la combinación de esta vacuna
pues suscita algunas necesidades de
estudio de mayor información por ahora
lo importante es si se hace una dosis
adicional procurar que sea la misma
marca y si no el que sean vacunas
rn con vacunas de virus inactivados o
con vacunas de vectores virales y eso se
va a ir implementando poco a poco en la
región doctor segundo tema de la agenda
que ha generado muchísimo expectativa a
lo largo de esta semana y es esa píldora
de la farmacéutica pfiezer y también de
la farmacéutica merck de qué se trata en
qué forma nos puede beneficiar este tipo
de medicamentos para enfrentar el hobby
19 prevenir que nos de kobe 19 o para
sortear mejor si ya estamos contagiados
con kobe 19 que se sabe en la comunidad
científica
es una gran noticia porque además de las
vacunas necesitábamos medicamentos
eficaces
este es un medicamento antiviral
recordemos que todo lo que estamos
usando en oil era para controlar la
inflamación y el medicamento estos
medicamentos antivirales directos
demostraron en sus estudios fase 3 que
son estudios en miles de personas y en
varias regiones que incluye 50 por
ciento de la probabilidad de
hospitalización y reduce de 14 asiento a
7 por ciento la probabilidad de un
hobbit severo es decir para controlar
una pandemia se necesita educación
social vacunas y tratamientos efectivos
este es un paso gigantesco al de
tratamientos efectivos y estamos muy
esperanzados y prometedores y pendientes
de revisar los datos de que nos aporten
ms y fisher en los próximos en las
próximas semanas pues excelente noticia
ojalá esto dé buenos resultados porque
sería ya entonces la tercera pieza de
este rompecabezas que nos ayudaría a
empezar a hacerle frente mucho más
fuertes el commit 19 paso al siguiente
tema y es un estudio de la universidad
de vanderbilt en eeuu que descubrió que
hay un anticuerpo ultra potente contra
las diferentes variantes del cob y 19 de
qué se trata que es un anticuerpo
ultrapotente esto como beneficia al
cuerpo o esto nos juega en contra de qué
se trata esto
esto es estos son todos los procesos que
hay para disecar el sistema inmunológico
en nuestro sistema de defensas para
poder neutralizar el virus lo que se
encuentre lo que se documenta es que
cada vez hay mayor precisión sobre ian y
cuerpos y defensas actúan sobre el
coronavirus pero lo que es muy
importante es que si pueden neutralizar
varían desde el coronario no solamente
no harían sino todas las variantes podrá
estos anticuerpos ser el target para
hacer una vacuna ésta está digamos
descripción de este tipo anticuerpos lo
que permite la reformulación de unas
vacunas de segunda o tercera generación
que permitan controlar las variantes
alfa beta gamma lambda y todas las del
abecedario porque sería una vacuna que
neutralizaría completamente estas
familias esperemos los anticuerpos esto
es un primer paso pero es un paso hacia
adelante en el control de la pandemia
bueno muy buenas noticias entonces a lo
largo de esta semana con todo esto que
nos está explicando dr otro tema que
tenemos en la agenda
las evidencias que hay de síntomas de
estrés por la pandemia estrés post cobit
en los niños en los menores en los
menores de edad cómo afrontarlo cómo se
puede detectar que un menor está
presentando síntomas de estrés si ya
sufrió un kobe 19 o simplemente por la
situación en la que hemos estado a lo
largo de prácticamente dos años
y creo que uno de los grandes retos que
tuvimos durante la pandemia y que
estudiamos un poco fue la salud mental y
la situación de encierro o la paranoia
el miedo de la muerte la incertidumbre
de la desagregación familiar la pérdida
de familiares pues afecta a la población
infante pero además de eso los niños que
sufren cobit tienen esos problemas y
además un problema mental de estrés que
se ha descrito en las poblaciones
infantiles pues este es un llamado la
pedagogía que cuidemos a nuestros niños
a que hablemos con franqueza de la
enfermedad para que no nos
aterrorizaremos por lo que estamos
viviendo sino que seamos realistas
porque es el mejor remedio para el
estrés la buena información y la
comunicación aquí es donde padres
escuelas colegios profesores y
comunidades debemos regar a los niños y
no llenarlos de malas noticias sino
esperanza gran tema doctor creo que esto
valdría la pena profundizar un poco más
en el cierro esta agenda hablando de los
síntomas que trae el cubit después de
haberlo padecido ya teníamos la disnea
pérdida del gusto la pérdida del olfato
ahora parece que hay que añadir también
el síndrome de colon irritable
digamos que hay una gran manifestación
de síntomas por ejemplo lo que hemos
visto con esta variante delta es que
todas las alteraciones en el olfato y
las alteraciones gastrointestinales han
estado presentes siempre la pandemia
este es un virus que tiene esa capacidad
de inflamar el intestino algunos
estudios han mostrado que hay disfunción
de la motilidad intestinal en pacientes
por coidh es algo que hay que evaluar
pero hay que tener en cuenta que también
las presente enfermas por post se puede
manifestar como diarrea no
necesariamente como una inflación de
colon sino como diarrea como parte del
cortejo sintomático en conclusión
digamos que cada día aprendemos más hay
que estar mucho más pendientes y si uno
tiene un problema de salud lo que debe
consultar es el médico y no las redes
sociales ni google porque en un medio
una pandemia necesitamos descartar la
enfermedad y poder actuar aquí doctor
pérez como siempre un gusto muchas
gracias por aclarar para nuestra
audiencia todas estas dudas gracias por
habernos acompañado pues ya lo estamos
mencionando la farmacéutica merck
anunció que su pastilla contra el kobe
de 19 de 12 las posibilidades de
hospitalización y también de muerte
y contraer el kobe 19 en un 50% este
medicamento ya está en fase 3 veamos
una posible nueva herramienta en la
lucha contra el hobbit 19 se llama mon
lupera beer y es el antiviral
experimental de la farmacéutica merck
cuyos resultados sorprenden a la
comunidad médica la pastilla promete la
reducción de las posibilidades de
hospitalización o muerte en un 50% tras
contraer el virus y
disponer de una pastilla para prevenir
la evolución a una enfermedad grave
cambiaría la forma de tratarla
las personas podrían ir a su farmacia y
tomar su medicación de la misma manera
que lo hacen con otros medicamentos esto
nos permitiría tratar a muchas más
personas con mayor rapidez y menos
gastos extensos está se administra a los
pacientes que han contraído el cubit 19
recientemente y se toman dos dosis
diarias durante cinco días entre las 775
personas que se sometieron a la fase 3
del estudio no hubo muertes entre los
pacientes que tomaron el mono pira beer
y sólo ocho personas del grupo que tomó
el placebo murieron tras el experimento
la noticia tuvo sus impactos en el
mercado mientras que las acciones de
merck subieron un 12%
de los fabricantes de vacunas como facer
o modernas cayeron a pesar de que las
autoridades sanitarias consideran que
los resultados son impresionantes
defienden la vacunación como primera
opción
si se aprueba creo que la forma correcta
de pensar en esto es que se trata de una
herramienta adicional para proteger a
las personas de los peores resultados
del cobi 19 creo que es realmente
importante recordar que la vacunación
sigue siendo de lejos la mejor de
nuestras armas
beijing no obstante el gobierno ya ha
cerrado un contrato de 17 millones de
dosis con merck que se materializará
siempre y cuando las autoridades
sanitarias aprueben su uso de emergencia
el próximo objetivo del laboratorio es
desarrollar las pastillas para que se
puedan usar también para prevenir el
cubit 19 hablamos ahora de perú hubo
novedades novedades positivas esta
semana en este país suramericano han
disminuido los casos de contagio y
también el número de víctimas vamos a
conocer los detalles con francisco
zacarías en la ciudad de lima francisco
buenas tardes gracias por acompañarnos
precisan lima la capital que es donde
usted se encuentra hubo días de esta
semana en los que no se registraron
víctimas mortales por kobe 19
santiago esto podría ser quizás la mejor
noticia en perú desde que comenzaron los
contagios del cobi 19 el ministerio de
salud de anunciado que por primera vez
desde que se inició la pandemia este
lunes no se registraron fallecidos en
lima y no sólo eso las autoridades
sanitarias señalan que ese día en todo
el país solo murieron muchos ciudadanos
por el coronavirus precisan que 7 ellos
no estaban vacunados el reporte revela
que las muertes por sharp scott 2 en las
últimas 22 semanas van en descenso esto
es tomado como una victoria parcial sin
embargo el gobierno exhorta a la
población al no contagiarse ni bajar la
guardia y continuar cumpliendo los
protocolos sanitarios y vacunarse contra
el kobe y 19 la estrategia es que
mientras más peruanos estén vacunados
habrá menos restricciones por la
emergencia sanitaria y menor número de
fallecidos en una tercera ola francisco
entonces hablemos de las cifras de
contagiados y de fallecidos a nivel
nacional en todo el territorio peruano
el último reporte del ministerio de
salud de este país revela 516 contagios
y 17 fallecidos durante las últimas 24
horas mientras que el registro acumulado
existen más de 2 millones 176 mil casos
confirmados y más de 199 mil 300
fallecidos por kobe 19 en cuanto a los
hospitalizados se contabilizan más de 3
mil 800 pacientes internados de los
cuales más de mil se encuentran en
unidad de cuidados intensivos con
ventilación mecánica y hablando de los
que vencieron el virus más de 2 millones
152 mil personas cumplieron su periodo
de aislamiento domiciliario o fueron
dados de alta
fernando ceballos ministro de salud
señaló que perú se encuentra viviendo
una especie de silencio epidemiológico
sin embargo el sector se mantiene en
alerta porque la variante delta se
encuentra en todas las regiones 18 veces
más contagiosa y agresiva por su parte
el instituto nacional de salud ha
detectado la presencia de la mutación
delta bruce que se dice es muy
infecciosa y disminuye la capacidad de
la defensa de las vacunas francisco así
las cosas como está avanzando la
vacunación entonces en ese país
pero aplicado es el momento más de 26
millones
496 dosis de vacuna contra el cob y 19
de los cuales más de 15 millones 764 mil
corresponden a la primera dosis y más de
10 millones 729 mil a la segunda dosis
las autoridades afirman que existe un
avance del 38 por ciento de la población
objetivo se está desplegando brigadas en
todo el país para llevar el fármaco a la
población que habita en los andes' la
selva y de ciertos extensos en paralelo
se ha autorizado la transferencia de más
de 173 millones de dólares para la
adquisición de vacunas contra el cob y
19 el ministerio de salud anunció la
llegada de más de 12 millones de dosis
durante el mes de octubre con los de
seis seres scinopharm mientras el
gobierno cierra nuevos acuerdos con los
laboratorios modernas y facer para la
compra de 55 millones de dosis de
vacunas contra el sarcoptes durante el
año 2022 francisco gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de lima la
capital de perú y les cuento brevemente
otras noticias destacadas a lo largo de
esta semana la farmacéutica sanofi
existe desarrollar su vacuna de aire en
el mensajero similar a la de facer la
compañía indicó que usará esa plataforma
para otros desarrollos sanofi también
afirmó que seguirá con el desarrollo de
su vacuna basada en una proteína
recombinante brevemente también les
cuento que sólo 15 de los más de 55
estados del continente africano han
logrado inocular el 10 por ciento de la
población esto deja en evidencia la
inequidad y también el acceso o el
difícil acceso a las vacunas y lo atrás
que está a áfrica para alcanzar un
control de la pandemia o una inmunidad
del rebaño y también brevemente brasil
superó los 590 mil muertos por cuenta
del cob y 19 los números son sin embargo
a nivel nacional han mostrado un leve
descenso desde hace dos meses gracias al
avance de la vacunación en los
diferentes estados brasileños
y la inequidad en la repartición de las
vacunas se ha convertido en un tema
crítico para los países de américa
latina' así lo expresaron los
mandatarios de la región durante el
consejo permanente de la organización de
estados américanos el secretario general
de esta organización luis almagro se
refirió a este tema
la necesidad de acelerar la vacunación
necesitamos más dosis este hemisferio
necesita más dosis nuestros países
necesitan más dosis y definitivamente
ese es el camino hacia adelante
para
recuperar el tejido social para
reafirmar el crecimiento de la economía
y para asegurar las condiciones de salud
de la población en diferente y ahora
demos un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con el cob y 19 destacadas
en redes el diario el late time se
titula la o ms propone a los países de
américa un acuerdo ante futuras
pandemias el director de lado ms pedrosa
da hmong ebre jesús pidió a américa que
apoye un acuerdo para afrontar las
pandemias esto tras el impacto causado
por el hobby 19 la región en el marco de
un mecanismo común habría una garantía
de seguridad sanitaria en la región y en
el mundo así lo afirmó el director
general y miren esta publicación de
france 24 punto com elaborada por
nuestra compañera más romeros editora de
salud del programa directo américa
titula cobit largo el 37 por ciento de
las personas contagiadas mantienen algún
síntoma meses después de padecer esta
enfermedad los hemos mencionado acá los
síntomas van desde ansiedad depresión
dolor de pecho fatiga entre otros así lo
indica un estudio que fue presentado por
la universidad de oxford en el reino
unido- aquí los hemos mencionado y la
lista sigue aumentando con el paso de
las semanas a medida que avanzan las
investigaciones en torno a esta
enfermedad
es todo por el momento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos encontramos en
8 días sigan cuidándose sigan usando el
tapaboca sigan lavándose las manos en
nombre de todo el equipo de france 24 de
la productora del aura garzón los
dejamos por acá y nos vemos en la
programación de france 24 hasta entonces
[Música]